presupuestos de acción en medio de una
huelga masiva este miércoles el gobierno
británico anunció su plan económico para
acelerar la economía de Reino Unido la
cual asegura sobrevivirá la crisis
hoy la oficina de responsabilidad
presupuestaria pronostica que debido a
factores internacionales cambiantes y
las medidas tomadas el Reino Unido no
entrará en una recesión técnica este año
pero las calles al sentir es otro
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estos médicos han estado en huelga desde
el lunes como decenas de miles de sus
colegas En toda Inglaterra a 14 libras y
19 peniques la hora dicen que un médico
recién titulado gana menos que el
personal de una cafetería
años de aumento salariales por debajo de
la inflación significan que han sufrido
un recorte salarial del 26% desde 2008
Mientras tanto la carga de trabajo y las
listas de espera de los pacientes están
en máximos históricos alejando a decenas
de médicos de la sanidad pública por
agotamiento
he trabajado y me he formado durante
años y años acumulando deudas pagando
exámenes pagando tasas y no puedo
permitirme llevar una vida básica nos
hemos ocupado de la gente pero tenemos
la sensación de que las personas que
deberían ocuparse de nosotros nuestros
empleadores y el gobierno han Renegado
en cierto modo de ese acuerdo sus quejas
resuenan en todo el sector público
cientos de miles de trabajadores han
abandonado este miércoles sus puestos de
trabajo reclamando que sus salarios
sigan al ritmo de la inflación que sigue
por encima del 10%. se espera que el
paro de dos días de los profesores
afecte a todas las escuelas de
Inglaterra y el paro del personal
ferroviario en Londres ha paralizado
toda la red de metro
los sindicatos muestran pocos signos de
desgaste para poner fin a unas huelgas
que comenzaron el año pasado pero el
gobierno sigue resistiéndose a sus
demandas mientras dice que quiere
trabajar con los gremios para lograr
textualmente aumentos salariales justos
y razonables pero solos si termina el